[Musica]
dobbiamo cambiare la corsia che stiamo
andando in contro mano siamo pigri un po
per caso abbiamo solo sul divano in
autostrada c'è la coda perché ho
investito una mimosa
casa a cucinare ciò il biscotto da
infornare apriamo questa macchina e
rubiamo lo schiera
poi ci beccherà la pula e finiremo i
tribunali
mi rendo sin da ragazzo
abbondanza
sei senza terra
cosa fare faccio una risonanza e dopo fu
giro in ambulanza
siamo albanesi in brianza
umbria
comunque questo video è soltanto un
altro plagio l'ho copiato da amedeo come
infusa te per il disagio al party siamo
giorni martin non ci abbiano i
carboidrati ci proviamo un po con tutti
anche se siamo invertebrati tua sorella
metallara che sta indietro con gli esami
regalo una maglietta ma io testo solo a
mano in cima gialla
c'è star la bilancia
il cibo
[Musica]
abbiamo il frigobar
vietato
d ci mangiamo potenza
siamo youtube esca avanza
youtube e cavani
tu non le sa fare le granite le tisane
non esistono ragazze belle come le
befane non facciamo che a sbagliare
mangiamo le banane guardiamo le valigie
proprio come fa il mio cane il mio
padrone si raglia quando poi mi
accompagna
ma dice che una gran cagnara abbiamo
fino in fondo per trovarla castagna
anche se poi alla fine si bagna
siamo due alani in campagna
a
[Musica]